Did you spot the Nazi references in "The Lion
King"? Or the "2001" homage in "Wall-E"? Bowie in
"Moana"? These are just a few of the many things
that only adults notice about cartoon villains.
The Cartoon Network series "The Powerpuff Girls"
might just be the cutest take ever on superheroes.
Debuting in 1998, Blossom, Bubbles, and Buttercup
are kindergarten-aged children who protect their
town as super-powered beings. The girls have a
great rogue's gallery filled with villains who
are often just as brightly-drawn and cute as the
heroines, from Princess Morbucks to Mojo Jojo.
But amidst all that cuteness lies a disturbing
anomaly known as His Infernal Majesty or simply,
HIM. This strange red creature
has a soft, seductive voice,
horn-like ears, a goatee, and thigh-high
boots that look an awful lot like hooves.
And his aim isn't world domination, it's to
corrupt the Powerpuff Girls' innocent natures.
In other words, he's Satan. Not exactly what
you usually expect from a kid's cartoon.
Dr. Heinz Doofenshmirtz is the main villain
of "Phineas and Ferb," which began airing
in 2007. A classic mad scientist with improbable
inventive skills, Doofenshmirtz's dearest wish is
to conquer the tri-state area. Doofenshmirtz
doesn't have a lot of friends or family,
but he is deeply attached to his daughter
Vanessa. He can often be seen worrying about
her and saving her from trouble, and he even gives
up being evil for her sake in the series finale.
All of that makes Doofenshmirtz one
of the top parents in cartoon history,
despite being viewed as an evil villain. In
fact, Doofenshmirtz is a far better parent
than even Phineas and Ferb's parents. Every
episode of the show has the boys engaging in
an outrageous adventure, with no adult around
to stop them from building rollercoasters,
messing with time travel, engineering giant
robots, or traveling between dimensions.
Seriously, the attitude of Phineas and Ferb's
parents borders on the neglectful — especially
when compared to the lengths that Doofenshmirtz
goes to while trying to protect Vanessa.
Disney fairytales tend to stay away from lewdness,
keeping in mind their very young audience. Most
Disney villains are motivated by PG-13 impulses,
like a desire for magical power or
wealth. Not so with Judge Frollo,
the main villain of 1996's "The Hunchback of
Notre Dame." Frollo was all kinds of messed up.
As the Minister of Justice, Frollo was
highly disturbed by the unusual passions
awakening in his bosom at the sight of the
beautiful Esmeralda. In fact, Frollo sings
an entire song, "Hellfire," about how hot he is
for Esmeralda, how his feelings are her fault,
and how he will not rest until he gets
with her whether she's into him or not.
It's extremely disturbing watching a
Disney character sing about his desire
to assault the heroine. How this film
got a G rating is a mystery to everyone.
Sid Phillips from 1995's "Toy Story" managed to
be a terrifying villain despite only being an
11-year-old kid. That was because Sid delighted
in breaking apart toys and reconstructing them in
grotesque, horrific ways. The obvious pleasure Sid
takes in mutilating beautiful little toys would
sound alarm bells for any psychiatrist,
as well as child protective services.
Sid displays classic signs of a child
who has suffered neglect and abuse.
In the movie, we get a brief glimpse of Sid's
father asleep on a reclining chair — a deer
head mounted on the wall shows that Mr. Phillips
likes to inflict violence on others. The fact that
he is asleep in the middle of the day shows he
is likely jobless, and the many empty beer cans
littering the room likely indicate an alcoholic
who doesn't take care of his surroundings.
All these hints, alongside Sid's fear of waking
his father up, point towards the Phillips
household being an unhappy one. How much of Sid's
sadistic impulses are the result of his father may
be debatable, but this much is clear: The kid is
seeking an outlet for his anger by hurting toys.
Disney often makes use of pop culture icons
while creating their animated characters,
a trend that included 2016's "Moana" via Tamatoa,
a giant flamboyant crab that
craves shiny, valuable objects.
For older viewers, Tamatoa's look might evoke
memories of iconic glam-rock singer-songwriter
David Bowie, and that is no accident. The
look of Tamatoa was in fact based on Bowie,
and the character's big musical number
"Shiny" was written with Bowie in mind,
as the film's songwriter Lin-Manuel
Miranda told People in 2016.
"I'd been listening to Bowie
on a loop. I was like, well
I'm writing a glam rock tune for this
crab, this jewel-encrusted crab."
To channel the spirit of Bowie further, Tamatoa
was voiced by New Zealand's Jemaine Clement,
who has been known to bust
out a credible impression
of Bowie in projects like "Flight of the
Conchords." Clement told The AU Review,
"When I tried to record ["Shiny"]
in the character's voice,
[Miranda] just kept pushing the Bowie thing, do it
more Bowie, he wanted glam, like a T-Rex Bowie."
Ursula from 1989's "The Little Mermaid" is as
rollickingly entertaining as a Disney villain
can get. Which makes sense, because she was
based on a rollickingly entertaining drag queen.
Rob Minkoff, animator for "The Little
Mermaid," revealed in the 2020 Disney+
documentary "Howard" that he came up with a
host of possible designs for Ursula's character,
including one based on famed drag queen Divine,
best known for playing Edna in 1988's "Hairspray."
When the film's lyricist Howard Ashman
saw the drawings, the choice was clear.
"And that design was put on a board with
a bunch of other designs and the day that
Howard Ashman came in to look at the
designs he zeroed in on that one."
Truly divine!
1994's "The Lion King" is generally agreed
to be one of the greatest Disney movies of
all time. Despite being a story about talking
animals, the movie was grounded in mature themes
as it took its cues from the Biblical stories
of Joseph and Moses, William Shakespeare's
"Hamlet" — and also from the infamous
Nazi propaganda films of Leni Riefenstahl.
In the song "Be Prepared," sung by the movie's
main bad guy Scar, we see Hyenas marching past
the villainous lion in a highly regimented style.
The movements of the Hyenas, and the view of
their formations, was based specifically
on Nazi propaganda films by Riefenstahl.
According to Entertainment Weekly, the idea
for the song came from a sketch by story
staffer Jorgen Klubien that pictured Scar as
Hitler, which inspired the directors to craft
the "Be Prepared" sequence, which became
one of the most iconic parts of the film.
Pixar is a studio that excels in telling
stories filled with warmth and empathy.
Stanley Kubrick was a filmmaker renowned for
telling stories filled with tension, coldness
and dread. The two might not seem to have much
of an overlap at first blush, but 2008's "Wall-E"
brought the two together in an unexpected manner
through the introduction of its main villain.
In "Wall-E," the central antagonist
is a rogue A.I. called Auto that has
control of a vessel carrying humanity
into the furthest reaches of space.
Auto's looks and personality are clearly based
on the villainous HAL 9000 from Kubrick's "2001:
A Space Odyssey." But the references
don't end there. A scene from "2001"
where an ape learns to use tools features
the same music as the scene in "Wall-E"
when the Captain of Auto's space vessel
finally leaves his chair to stand on his feet,
learning self-reliance in the process after having
depended on Auto for everything for so many years.
2005's Disney film "Chicken Little"
was a heartfelt story about growing up,
standing up for your beliefs, and learning to
let your children become self-reliant. And it
also paid homage to one of the most influential,
terrifying sci-fi novels of all time, H.G. Wells'
1897 masterpiece "The War of the Worlds," which
features aliens landing in terrifying tripods.
Fortunately, the machines in "Chicken Little"
were a lot more benign than the ones that
showed up in "The War of the Worlds." It
is revealed in the final act of the movie
that the aliens initially visited Earth just to
gather acorns, and later returned with an entire
armada because they thought one of their
own was being held hostage by Earthlings.
Once the misunderstanding is cleared up, the
aliens return peacefully to their home planet.
For multiple generations of children, the
"Tom and Jerry" cartoons have been a popular
retelling of the classic "David vs. Goliath"
narrative. In this case, the big, dim-witted cat
Tom is the evil Goliath, while the smaller,
quick-witted Jerry is plucky little David,
who humbles the giant with his brains and will
power. But is the story really that simple?
Once you grow up and need to look
into buying or renting your own house,
you begin to realize what a major
problem house pests like mice can be,
which is why house pets like cats are used
to eliminate pests and keep the home safe.
Once you start looking at the situation from
that angle, you realize that Jerry was the
villain of the show, an uninvited house pest
that ran roughshod all over the house eating
and taking whatever he wanted. Meanwhile, Tom
was simply the house pet trying to do what it
had been trained to accomplish, keeping the home
safe from unwanted rodents. Sure, Tom was always
left frustrated after his encounters with Jerry —
but just imagine how Tom's owners must have felt.
So if you think Jerry is the
good guy, all we can say is
"Don't you believe it!!"
Adult innuendo in cartoons aimed
at children is not a new thing.
But sometimes the innuendo is so in-your-face
you can't help but be surprised by the audacity
of the show's writers. Case in point,
Roxy Rocket's appearance in "The New
Batman Adventures," where she had a
singular obsession with getting laid.
In the episode "The Ultimate Thrill,"
viewers are introduced to Roxy,
a daredevil stuntwoman who turned to a life of
crime to satisfy her craving for excitement.
In Roxy's mind, her reaction to
danger is quite similar to arousal.
Roxy's weapon of choice is a giant, phallic
rocket, and she soon becomes obsessed with Batman.
Throughout the episode, Roxy makes one charged
comment after another, telling Penguin about
Batman, quote, "I was the best he ever had,"
and, "I love a man with staying power."
But the most brazen scene comes at the end. When
Roxy's last daring heist is stopped by Batman,
she appears to be in the throes of ecstasy.
"Me and you! Yeah, yeah, YEAH!!!"
2010's "Despicable Me" had you rooting
for the bad guy. Felonious Gru was an
aspiring super-villain who dreamed of pulling
off the ultimate heist to prove himself.
So he was forced to go to the Bank
of Evil, an organization that offers
loans to supervillains who can prove
their schemes are sufficiently evil.
However, the entrance to the
bank is hidden behind a urinal.
But the truly dastardly touch is that
the entrance is behind the middle urinal.
When you go to a public restroom,
most people's instinct is to use the
urinal to the left or the right, because that
minimizes the chance of having to pee standing
next to someone. Only someone truly evil and
twisted would willingly use the middle urinal,
where he could be flanked on both
sides by others. It is exactly that
kind of a dastardly mind that the Bank of Evil
would be interested in doing business with.
The Evil Queen from 1937's "Snow White and
the Seven Dwarfs" might just be the most
iconic Disney villain of all time. She's often
portrayed as the personification of evil, but
adults might be more likely to diagnose her as
suffering from Narcissistic Personality Disorder.
NPD, also referred to as Megalomania, is a mental
condition which has been officially recognized
by the American Psychiatric Association. People
suffering from NPD have an exaggerated sense of
their own importance, as well as a deep need for
excessive attention and admiration. This in turn
leads to the sufferer having trouble maintaining
relationships due to a lack of empathy for others.
These symptoms fit the Evil Queen to a T. The
tragic part is, NPD is actually treatable,
but the people who suffer from it have
such a high opinion of themselves that
they refuse to recognize they have
a problem that requires therapy.
The Evil Queen's time could have been
put to much better use if she had stopped
obsessing over Snow White so much and booked an
appointment with the Dwarf named "Doc" instead.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite villains are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.